[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record and we talk about
whatever we want yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] i like your shirt fear of mom
instead of fear of god yeah
i see what they did there funny yeah i
was trying to read it earlier and i
couldn't it's a parody shirt the other m
so i was like fear of money i was trying
to guess what it said because i
hadn't seen it but shout outs to asians
never die
he made this shirt because i'm the og
asian mom
he's like yeah he's like this you have
to have this because
that's so dope right now with your hair
you passed uh
park you you passed it now you're going
into the asian mom world
asian mom is your hair wet yeah oh i
just took a shower
your hair is so black dude why is it so
black
it's just it's just black my mom always
thinks i dye my hair too whenever yeah
you have black hair too
yeah so does bark yeah really really
darker oh
yeah i guess he always well that's true
because jason's hair is a little brown
yeah a little brown a little bit really
yeah you look like you have soft hair it
does look very soft it does look very
soft
yeah do you have soft is your pubes
that's off too i don't know
you don't know how do you not know we
don't know about that let's put
them on the spot are your pupils soft or
are they like
fully
i'm usually like pretty clean down there
so i don't really oh you shave it off
nice you're not sponsored by manscaped
are you
he might be if he's shaving oh i use my
manscape i like how he has no words just
keep going
you shave don't you get ingrown oh yeah
you got thin hair
you shave all the way like this see
i i used to shave but i get ingrown
hairs you shave your balls with a razor
or with like a clipper and there's like
a five o'clock shot
like he doesn't even have hair on his
balls uh razor like you're that clean
with a razor yeah so wait he's like a
baby mouse
wait do you go hair on your balls or not
i do like three right
yeah like very few see i knew it you
look like the type at that point yeah
have you ever no you think you could oh
okay i have so few there that i can just
see now i don't grow hair on my balls at
all i'm surprised really
like no all my pubes are around
like my genital region like a lion's
light but like not on the actual balls
yeah how about the base though okay okay
so yes the brush
so yes it's like okay so it's my dick it
supports your dick
pubes uh pubes okay so like he's
painting it
is all the people here okay so like okay
here let's see let's say like okay so
like uh
so here's here's my dick here's my dick
uh pubes up here yes
me too um and then yes yes around the
base
and then around the testicle but on the
actual balls it's smooth
if we were a a kid show i would show you
guys my dick
for scientific purposes a kids show but
i'll show you the educational journey
oh that's what he meant it's like here
and then triangle it's a triangle
oh and then and then it wraps around
and it wraps around like this and it
connects to my butt
wait so did you yeah i was about to say
that he's like
oh okay jason can you show us what yours
look like i like joe's demonstration
mine's basically exactly like tim pube
twins
and then our [ __ ] are hairy as [ __ ]
i have a ring around the rosie do you
shave your [ __ ]
no i don't really you should because
well how she gives you rim jobs
i don't i'm not a fan of room jobs dude
what that's
that's joe's [ __ ] that is disgusting to
me
he's yucking your yum bro do you know
what your butthole looks like
have you ever bent over and spread them
and look in the mirror you should
how you how do you know if you shaved it
clean it's your stuff
because it's like what if you didn't
shave it clean and you have like one
straggler
it's like a guy that has one curly
mustache on one side like the guy with
the mold with the hair
speaking of [ __ ] i just got a good
look at mine because i
had a hemorrhoid oh edward saw it dude
scared of it did you see it and go oh
that's me
no well i always like they're pretty
similar
oh i'm scared to look at mine i want to
know what you're afraid of
what are you scared of i mean you're the
one that sticks your finger up your ass
he says he folds well i clean my
butthole really nice
but i don't want to like like i'm
surprised
how do you clean it so every every night
i get soap and i stick it in and i go
see no you do you do that for real yeah
you put soap on your finger that's why
and then you periscope your [ __ ]
now how do you get the soap out of it
yeah you just so when the water is going
down your bodies go baby
clean it put your finger blast your
[ __ ] yeah wait so you're gonna do
that
well you can't get rim jobs it's that
and also
you're gonna shake your butt so you
could be cleaner i don't shave my butt
well i'm scared of like you know when
you grow you when you cut your pubes and
it starts growing out and it's all that
itchy face
yeah so i don't want that itchy face
between my butthole because i'll be
scratching my butthole all the time over
that hump
how do you get over that hump well i
would laser shaving or a laser laser no
i want to you should oh wait you shave
your [ __ ] too
i don't know how to shave if i'm going
on a date okay i'm here just in case
but sometimes i forget do you shave the
girls that have to deal with that
y'all [ __ ] and the ladies y'all are
like waxed or lasered you're lazy your
[ __ ] are totally lasered
whoa wait do you shaving cream on your
[ __ ]
yeah i have to what oh well i mean it
hurt i mean it feels like how do you get
in there without me
oh you okay i i run my fingers before
the blade
so i do one of these oh i do want to
straight up bend over like that
do one of these like what like so like
that is so dangerous you guide it yeah
so like if this is the razor
i i i go like this and then i feel the
hair and i do it extremely soft and you
have a mirror on the floor
no how do you know where you're going
his eyes are his fingers dude
his fingertips are his eyes yeah oh so
you kind of you got to feel it out and
then you feel it out
and you feel it out and then you feel it
out and then you you
see it on the razor and then when it's
gone
yeah it it hurts but then also i stopped
doing it as much
because yeah i do be cutting my balls
and [ __ ] you know
and it's with a razor you use a razor on
your balls
yeah did it lose skin like elbow like
you gotta pull it tight yeah but you
gotta
you gotta be super soft you just gotta
run it
really like i mean when i'm a geezer
right i'm gonna look like a hamster
anyway like a
fat houser that lost weight so i'm
assuming that i gotta do it the same way
it's really easy you've been practicing
on your balls for your feet
wait you put your finger up your butt
every night i'm still stuck on that
i don't i don't get pleasure out of it i
know i know because i'm i'm really
paranoid about keeping my eyes all clean
too like i try to keep it really clean
but
i've never yeah no i've never done that
you don't care about it
don't say you care i guess not i want it
to be so i care about
cleanliness and i care about smell
mm-hmm so i always try to make sure that
i smell clean
so i want it to be uh even though joe
never does this but i want it to be if
she wanted thanks for the shout out
snort my butthole that it would just
smell like soap like fresh stuff
does that mean after you get out of the
shower and you dry yourself do you stick
your finger in there to make sure you're
good
i've never done that test i do i've done
that before we're not in there but like
but you just kind of push against the
hole and then like do a little just to
make sure that when i was a little kid i
used to be obsessed like
where i would be in bed obsessed with
what about making sure my butthole
smells like okay good not the [ __ ]
smelling no no no no
i used to love scratching my ass and
then smelling it i didn't love it
you see that's why i had to ask i didn't
know where it was going i would just
be like laying in bed and i'd be like
and i'd like before i fall asleep like
test i just kind of like like push like
just a little pre like press my butthole
bring the doorbell over over the
underwear though right no no no all my
actual [ __ ] oh my god you don't wash
your hand after that no well then like
if it didn't stink then it was no reason
to wash your hands because it was clean
yeah well what if you get cocka scraps
on it no then then i
no listen because if i if i if i smell
then it was sticky then i'd get out of
bed and i'd wash my hands you know
oh cause the thai people have that water
thing on the side and you could just
bidet your booty hole so if your ass
didn't smell you just go to sleep and
you have your like
your [ __ ] finger right next to your face
there's no [ __ ] did you ever play
but there's [ __ ] grease though no if
there's [ __ ] grease then i get out of
bed and wash my head i find hilarious
this is how low the standards are for
bart in this room
he literally just told everyone he
sticks his finger and [ __ ] bends it
and no one
[ __ ] batted it off everyone knows how
clean i am all you did was just go beep
boop
and then everyone's going in on you yeah
true well because i'm doing it in the
shower i'm clean right there is a
difference he's like i don't know what
he's doing
no look it's like this pretty disgusting
no no
it's like this ew don't touch it it's
like if you go
and your breath doesn't stink then you
know your breath doesn't work
yes there's no [ __ ] in your mouth have
you
okay there's [ __ ] stragglers right yeah
like i don't know how this happens
there's booty juice dude yeah there's
booty juice no this is me after i've
already
showered i've already washed my ass and
then i guess i can already
imagine what those fingers smell like
that's gross i guarantee you my ass
right now smells great let's go let's go
then
you'd be down to smell it well it
depends uh it depends how much of an
entertaining video we want i would be
you let me know what you want jk party i
don't know smell each other's bottles
let me know what you want i'm down
i feel i'm surprised we never did that
honestly i feel more comfortable
if we were all nude all day long because
i think wearing
underwear it traps this moisture and
then we get
like i actually feel the grease
well actually guys have different
material than chicks because i love like
a
satin or like we just have different
materials you guys just have cotton
the kylie still always wiping their ass
all day because they have a [ __ ]
ew you're gonna wear like looser clothes
and you won't feel bad
who guys are girls both if you wear
looser stuff but if you are ever in
trouble
and then like let's say you poop
yourself you're like oh no i can't leave
this place
i need to order some underwear or
something
who can go out and grab it for me good
thing that we are sponsored by postmates
because if you crap yourself and you own
you don't have no
other way to get clothes or whatever i'm
pretty sure you can get that
from postmates you can get anything from
postmates yup
what's the last thing that i got from
postmates that i was looking for
i was about to post made some elote the
other day oh you can't yeah i [ __ ] um
googled places like near me that looked
like they had like
pork corns yeah and they you know you
can get the little esquite in the in the
in the
bowl and then um they had it on the list
what they call it corn on the cob on the
thing but it was it wasn't a lot
cool that's dope no no need to track
down the man anymore
so if you're like any of us you'll
probably start thinking about what you
want to eat for dinner while you're
eating lunch
i love food and that's why i love using
postmates they deliver food from every
restaurant i can think of right to my
door
but post mates doesn't just deliver
burgers and sushi they actually make
life easier with grocery delivery
and whatever i can think of delivery to
convenience stores clothing stores even
hardware stores and
post me a screwdriver if you need to so
no more trips to the store
no more late night fast food runs you
can stay your ass home and keep watching
your favorite show while they deliver
food to you
i don't have to worry about where to
grab lunch anymore just download
postmates on ios or android and your
favorites
and find your favorites and get anything
you want delivered within the hour for a
limited time
postmates is giving our listeners 100
of free delivery credit for your first
seven days to start your free deliveries
download the app and use code
off the record baby that's code off the
record for 100
of free delivery credit with no minimum
purchase for your first seven days
when you download the postmates app
anything you need anytime you need it
postmate it
so evan with your hemorrhoid my doctor
well okay here's what happened right i
um did you pop it
no well i it's a vessel because i i
didn't have any like pain or anything so
i didn't even know i was there i just
had like a little bit of blood in my poo
blood yeah blood baby juice and i was
like and i was like huh
that's odd right and then i had to grab
your butthole that was a bloody nose
[Laughter]
no no yeah no i just held it up towards
the sky
[Laughter]
oh that feels good have you tried it
just like have your bare butthole
in the sky no but i'll check it out
later
uh while you're smelling it
but i uh and then like i was like okay
this is like you know because sometimes
you wipe a lot and you might be like a
little bit of blood but this was
different i was like
and then um on the follow-up pool it was
a tiny bit so i was like maybe i should
call the doctor
but then in the few days between i was
fine there was no blood i was like
i'm straight so i told the doctor i was
like hey it's probably just a random
thing that happened i don't know why but
there was like a little bit of blood in
my stool
she was like okay well i'm not gonna
insert anything i'm just gonna like take
a look all right i was like alright cool
so i get on [ __ ] a force no fetal
position
even worse yeah she's like okay just put
your knees into your chest like a fetal
position you know what i'm bottomless of
course got a little sheet over me
and then i feel her like open up my butt
she's just relaxed
and then she goes oh and there's a
hemorrhoid right there and she pokes it
right there oh and she was like
they don't all hurt you know she said
sometimes the the ones that are interior
don't usually hurt and she said mine was
kind of on the on the border
the extra ones hurt that's what i heard
i wouldn't know so she just told me to
kind of like
take some you know i'm i don't have i'm
never constipated
so she's just like take some stool
softeners just in case even though i
like i did it it's fine now
yeah um so when you poop it doesn't hurt
it's just when you're wiping you saw
blood
yeah rubs against it or something yeah
it bursts it oh
when you [ __ ] it bursts it yeah because
it's like it's like having a pimple
right which just goes away well she told
me yeah it's like she told me to take
like baths and kind of soak it in hot
water and [ __ ] i got a home girl
she was like dude because when i i put
on my story that i had a hemorrhoid
she's just like thin asian girl she's
like dude i've had the worst
constipation
and i get hemorrhoids the size of
cherries it's so bad
yeah it's like a swollen um vessel or
area like felt that that gets all
[ __ ] big and [ __ ] yeah from
from what i remember it's it's like a
blood vessel that popped out like a
hernia
you had one did you get on delivery do
it no not me what no i heard a lot of
women get it during pregnancy yeah
i didn't get anything because they're
pushing the only reason i knows because
of my
my old life when i used to sterilize
surgical instruments like the hemorrhoid
tray
one time they were a tray there's a
hemorrhoid treatment oh yeah there's a
collection of them
i don't know it's the tray of the
instrument their instrument
instruments surgical instruments oh and
there's cherries all over them
so oh my god in the decontamination room
that's where they bring them in
directly from surgery so they're all
bloody they should not
have any tissue like any human tissue
should not come to us in our department
but this one [ __ ] time when i
was washing that because you have to
rinse off the blood and stuff
so that was my have a splash guard on
your face yeah the full like the whole
ppe
that's why like with this whole corona
virus i've i'm like oh that's from my
old life like
being like i remember are you guys able
to have splash fights since both of you
guys have people ew
no we can't why don't we go go
no um so anyway one time they brought in
the hermoid tray and they
there's like this one um it looks like
this
it's a clamp i forgot what it's called
now but anyway that one this fly trap
that's the one where they grab they grab
the the the human tissue the hemorrhoid
that's when they like cauterize it or
whatever i don't know i didn't learn the
surgery part i just know the after part
so then they actually left the [ __ ]
hemorrhoid on the
this [ __ ] clamp by the time it was
into your freaking
was it flashback um it was like
it was like it was like this big
like this [ __ ] that's like a
dingleberry yeah it was
it was crazy and right there is where i
saw like
placentas coming in after labor delivery
all that
yeah did you guys eat your placentas
what the [ __ ]
why would you do that some people do
it's a thing yeah
they put it in pills they say
is it religious well sometimes and but
also people think that since the woman
loses so many nutrients on
birth they feel like no they give me no
nutrients give her protein shake
they feel like eating the placenta gives
the nutrients back into the body
in america i felt pretty good there's a
lot of ways to get nutrients like eagle
eggs
they give you no eagle powers are you
guys gonna eat cheese i want to
i i really want something i got sand
foods dude i want to have a [ __ ] i want
i don't
have it like raw like seriously no no
lightly yeah i don't want to do it like
a [ __ ] pill i want to like you know
garlic and onions that [ __ ]
and make it like a psychopath placenta
taco if it's not down i'll eat it
that episode i want to chase it with a
glass of breast milk too
i can't eat no human though i know that
is it's a human bits
that is cannibalism that's human it's my
own wife
oh yeah that's true you eat her but
still in a different way
yeah remember i was telling you i felt
when they pushed it when it came out of
me
all the placenta yeah yeah he pushed
here like
like he pushed really hard and i could
just feel like he just [ __ ]
sack just come home oh god i heard it
looks like lasagna i don't know my eyes
were cool a lot of [ __ ] comes out more
than just the well we have to specify
because [ __ ] means [ __ ] a lot of stuff
comes out more than just the baby [ __ ]
and but why would you want to eat the
sack though
because we just said nutrients man eagle
power you said it
no but still that don't make no sense
like there's so many nutrients what if
they what if they told you your dick
gets really hard
and grows two inches would you do it i
don't know i don't know it's already a
great size i'm used to it we have a
great relationship you know
but placenta you know what else i saw in
that room
a whole ass human leg it was [ __ ]
amputated yeah and they just left it
someone really didn't clean that
instrument the leg was stuck to the clap
no so so the surgical tech is the one
that brings in the the instruments and
so
i was friends with them so that he was
like hey before he went to the
incendiary because they're supposed to
burn that um he's like hey look do you
want to see a whole ass leg
holy [ __ ] there's a whole ass like all
the way up to the thigh like that like
yeah like from here it was it was the
whole [ __ ] leg
they couldn't keep it what did they use
to actually like amputate the legs this
looks like a giant
oh there's a lot why did they amputate
it did it have diseases or the chainsaw
i don't remember the reason but yeah no
yeah they have a chainsaw it's called
the
sag saw yeah i want to see it so it's
just like
sawing that's one of them no it's
motorized it's a motorized
yeah and we would disinfect those two
surgeons are like
car mechanics but for people that's
crazy they really are
yeah i kind of miss seeing all that
crazy stuff too i don't know why that
for some reason in the medical setting
i was just like so fascinated i'm like
oh my god i want to learn more
it's so scientific yeah but then when i
see this [ __ ] happening in movies or
something like
god damn it
that's too crazy so did your hammer go
away
yeah it's gone now i'm pretty sure well
you know it wasn't let's see
we'll let you know you just all up in my
[ __ ] today man i'm smelling it
looking at it i want to make you
uncomfortable and it just doesn't work
it's not damn the most comfortable
people
in the world i know i'm trying to push
the envelope here you gotta smell his
butthole he even gets
no i talked about his hair and he got
all squirmy
oh like forget it i'm a very
uncomfortable person
that'll make tim uncomfortable i know i
can't do it you have to like
maybe if i kiss him or something i don't
i think he'll kiss you back
actually there was when we were when we
shot that workout video the other day
um and i was doing the sit-ups i was
like [ __ ] i was [ __ ] with him and
every time i'll come up i was like
right and then bart was like bart was
like okay i'll kiss you for real and i
was like yeah
so there you go uh i need to see is he
spotting like was he holding
up his feet i was like every time you go
up like that bart's like all right i'm
coming back
because i was coming up johnny before i
was like one uh-huh
two and then i came up with like another
one he was like okay and i was like yeah
[Music]
you